découflé est l'invité du 19/20 ce soir
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors avant de poursuivre avec vous je
vous propose qu'on regarde ensemble un
extrait de ce spectacle on se retrouve
juste après alors ce spectacle philippe
découflé intitulé solo vous lui avez
créé je crois en 2003 pourquoi avoir
choisi de le montrer une nouvelle fois
au public 16 ans plus tard et bien en
fait c'est une chose donc je monte
surtout des spectacles pour des groupes
parfois des spectacles et dorment
parfois des plus petits mais j'ai
beaucoup de plaisir à retourner sur
scène parce que si je fais ce métier au
départ c'est pour ce plaisir là et ça me
fait du bien un tas de niveaux ça fait
du bien de retourner sur scène ça fait
du bien de danse et ça fait du bien de
partager soit même avec le public les
émotions qu'on a envie de partager
qu'est-ce que vous avez justement voulu
transmettre en vous retrouvant seul sur
scène pendant plus d'une heure on voit
les images qui défilent
qu'est ce que j'ai voulu transmettre bas
mon âme
ma joie de vivre en quelque sorte mais
sait plus comment dire c'est et j'ai eu
envie de faire ce solo le jour où j'ai
trouvé un truc vidéo permettant de me
dédoubler et je me suis dit que c'était
possible de faire un spectacle seul sans
être seul en créant en ayant des clown
et caetera
après je ne suis pas tout seul j'ai un
musiciens qui m'accompagnent
un vidéaste qui me film qui me autre
garçon qui fait tous les effets avec les
vidéos quelqu'un qui met clair quelques
kim soit d'horizon donc c'est un sextet
nous sommes six à travailler ensemble au
service d'une forme spectaculaire qui
est plutôt qui s'adresse à tout le monde
le travail d'équipé est ce que c'est il
ya quelque chose d'autobiographique
aussi dans ce spectacle là forcément
puisque c'est un solo donc je commence
par me présenter parlé un petit peu de
moi mais j'essaye assez vite d'emmener
le public sur divers chemins qui sont
plus de l'ordre du poétique du
géométrique du musical aujourd'hui venir
présenter votre travail à orléans comme
ailleurs en france
sortir des grands théâtres parisiens
allaient en province est ce que c'est
c'est important pour vous évidemment
c'est une grande partie de mon travail
de mon métier j'adore ça j'adore tourner
j'adore rencontrer des publics
différents
donc non évidemment moi je suis parisien
je travaille à paris mais je travaille
aussi partout dans le mans france dans
le monde donc non non c'est un plaisir
et un plaisir de revenir à orleix